here's an interesting voicemail I
received about the future for Andrew
yang let's take a listen to it the phone
number of course two one nine two David
P hey David I just want to know what you
think about Andrew Yang's future do you
think he's just going to disappear or do
you think he might somehow get into try
to aim for another seat
I believe I believe he's just going to
disappear until the next election next
election thank you yeah I've gotten
versions of this question from a few
people I don't think that Andrew yang is
angling for nor is he necessarily being
looked at by anybody for like a
cabinet-level position I just don't see
it I think it would be very plausible or
probable that after the Democratic
primary which I don't believe Andrew
yang is going to win I know there are
followers of his in my audience who say
any second now he's going to take the
lead I just don't see that I think that
he will do I think he will go back to
the business world maybe the interaction
of business and politics with the growth
in name recognition that he is garnered
as a result of his run for presidency I
don't know that I see Andrew yang even
particularly interested in just working
only within the political system if he's
not going to be president because I
think it would be quite frankly limiting
for him as someone whose background is
as an entrepreneur let me know what you
think we've got a great bonus show for
you today we will talk about an African
American security guard who was fired
after asking a student not to call him
the n-word that's crazy
he is now back to work we will also talk
about a push to have cars not allowed
drunk drivers to drive them this is a
technological push that exists and we
will talk about Mitt Romney's secret
Twitter account Pierre de lecto which is
just hilarious that's much better than
the fake names I use and I'll tell you
about some of those on the bonus show
join pakman.com to become a member and
get instant access to the bonus show